if you were the u.s what would you do
right now is it a
hey go spend a bunch of money in the
infrastructure build to set up mining
operations do you make bitcoin legal
tender
do you buy bitcoin and put it in the
balance sheet like what would you do if
max keiser is president and wants
bitcoin to be successful what does max
kaiser do
well i think i was the one who coined
the phrase hash war
uh maybe two and a half years ago that
countries would get into competitive
hashing
and because the idea is that governments
are not going to ban bitcoin
the smart governments are going to start
hoarding and and
mining bitcoin so to the extent that
the u.s becomes competitive they would
have to immediately
start to un underwrite mining
right so i mean that's what you'd have
to do
right away and that's the way to build a
solid economy going forward so
i would uh start directing funds toward
mining
and i would obviously look at a place
like texas where the cost of energy is
competitive globally
and build that out right away um
he who has the bitcoin makes the laws
and the countries that are really active
in this the most are going to be
extremely happy that they did
those countries that lag behind are are
going to be um
you know part of the new second world
right we're reordering
how what what constitutes a first world
nation
the first world nation will be heavily
into bitcoin and then the second and
third world would be
lagging in bitcoin so if the u.s wants
to be competitive they need to
immediately start directing resources
in in multiple ways to start to
accumulate and mine bitcoin my brothers
have a couple of questions for you but
before i let them ask
one more for you is uh the difference
between the federal government
and the states it seems like states seem
to be taking the lead here
uh is that a good thing should we
encourage more states to do that how do
you see the difference between the two
and
how that plays out for bitcoin right
well the us has an advantage over europe
in this regard that the states have
autonomy to a large degree
and they can push through laws and
and make big differences and we saw that
in the marijuana industry the states got
onto it first
and then it's heading up to the federal
level um
in the in europe though it's generally
more of an autocracy
top down from the ec the european
commission and there's very little room
to maneuver and
europe isn't a really bad shape pump i
mean i see in germany right now
the entire yield curve is negative and
more something many many banks almost
all the banks now are charging customers
negative
interest rates to hold their cash europe
is in
steep deep problems but in the us as you
point out that you do have the states
the states can be
are somewhat autonomous and they can
take the ball and run with it and we're
seeing it in wyoming
you know in miami the mayor's pro
bitcoin and that has a huge impact so
um we we can see uh
if if wyoming suddenly steals a lot of
business from delaware where a lot of
companies incorporate in delaware and
they start grabbing that whole business
and you see a migration to wyoming that
would have an impact
uh the miami economy is set to do well
based on the bitcoin
um in um you know activity there
and austin texas is becoming a huge
bitcoin hub texas is becoming huge texas
if the governor of texas could
could really break away and say we're
going to start
um mining bitcoin on the state level in
a big way
and it's a big state it's they they're
attracting congressional seats
they're pulling congressional seats away
from california
because peop so many people are leaving
california and they're they're becoming
more of a political powerhouse and if
they go
full-on bitcoin you know that's going to
be a huge difference i mean maybe that's
where i would put my efforts
you know more strategically is to get
one big state
fully onto bitcoin instead of trying to
get the federal government onto it
and that that i think that's a good
point i think that's a good idea
hey guys thanks so much for watching
that clip of the best business show make
sure you like and subscribe to the
channel
turn on notifications so you know when
we go live every weekday
and then head to sofi.com so that you
can get an account we can get after it